oh
the coconut oil
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
today's what i eat a day youtuber review
is going to be on riverdale superstar
madeleine pesch now you know i typically
review
a collection of what i in a day videos
by a youtuber
but in madeleine's case she's only got
one
and a lot of you sent this particular
video my way
and apparently even more of you actually
watched it
just look at those numbers so
crazy so this review will be short and
sweet so do
let me know if you like these kinds of
shorter videos in the mix
and before we get into the reviewing how
a vegan actor eats
of course a few quick disclaimers the
information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only
so you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
healthcare needs
also while i do make a really big effort
to include relevant and well researched
content in my videos
please keep in mind that what you see
may not fully reflect a creator's diet
as i cannot review a full catalog of
videos
featured on their channel however this
is the only
what in a day video on her channel also
please
be sure to be kind in the comments both
here and on madeline's channel
also a trigger warning that i will be
discussing numbers so
that may be disturbing to my viewers and
of course if that sounds like you
feel free to skip this video and don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out all right
let's eat
okay cool i mean you know i'm not one to
critique
someone's morning cup i really don't
care if you like your coffee with almond
milk or whole dairy milk or no milk or
sugar or stevia or whatever
you get your caffeine in however you see
fit
and let's move on how someone likes
their coffee in my opinion it's just so
personalized in my experience there's
never any point to telling somebody to
change it because it would just totally
ruin their whole
day having said that if you do want to
know what my thoughts are
on natural sweeteners like stevia you
can check out my video
right here i have a spoonful of coconut
oil with my breakfast
it's kind of disgusting but it's what my
nutritionist told me to do
yikes okay well
since madeleine says she has a hard time
getting in her healthy fats
her nutritionist suggested that she take
a spoonful of coconut oil
in the morning
oh no
okay where to start well first of all
when we talk about healthy fats
we're generally talking about the ones
that the research
is pretty clear have heart health
promoting benefits so
that is omega-3 polyunsaturated fats and
monounsaturated fats
you can get omega-3s in things like
fatty fish flax and walnuts
and you can get monounsaturated fats
from nuts seeds and avocado
healthy right we probably all can agree
but unlike almonds or hemp hearts
coconut oil
is predominantly saturated fat in fact
it's really high in saturated fat to
compare
one tablespoon of other sources of
saturated fat like butter
or ghee or cream all contain less than
10
grams of saturated fat per tablespoon
whereas one tablespoon of coconut oil
contains between 12 and 13 grams of
saturated fat
now is this really an issue well as i
discussed in my very
very in-depth video on saturated fats we
don't really know
research on saturated fat is really
controversial
with some suggesting that it may
increase the risk of heart disease
while other studies suggesting that
there's no association
the research on coconut oil specifically
is also pretty mixed
however most quality research suggests
that coconut oil can in fact raise
bad ldl cholesterol while also raising
good hdl cholesterol interestingly
despite being really high in saturated
fats
some research suggests that it does not
raise ldl cholesterol as
much as other saturated fats so it is
possible that the net effect isn't bad
for instance one 2017 randomized control
trial compared the effects of butter
coconut oil and olive oil on the
cholesterol levels of
96 men and women with no previous
history of chronic disease
despite being wildly different in
saturated fat content
there were no differences in the ldl
levels of those who were fed coconut oil
versus olive oil in contrast butter did
significantly
increase ldl cholesterol compared to the
coconut oil which was surprising
considering that
coconut oil is actually higher in
saturated fat than butter
the different effects of these two
saturated fats on cholesterol levels
likely has to do with their differences
in their fatty acid profiles
as coconut oil is made up of around
forty percent lauric acid
whereas butter is made up of mostly
palmitic
and stearic acids lauric acid is a
unique medium chain
fatty acid that's digested and
metabolized differently
from other fatty acids so studies have
shown that while lauric acid does
have cholesterol-raising effects is
proportionally higher for hdl
cholesterol
than ldl cholesterol another study in
women with abdominal obesity
also found that coconut oil increased
hdl cholesterol
and even helped to reduce waist
circumference the other reason why
coconut oil has been
so health washed lately is because those
mcts that we talked about
may also have some modest fat burning
properties
unfortunately most coconut oil only
contains around
50 percent mcts and the mct that is most
rich in
lauric acid doesn't really appear to
have as many of those
ketogenic fat burning benefits compared
to
caperic or capric acid both of which
together
only make up around 12 percent of
coconut oil's fat
with all of this in consideration
despite coconut oil being high in
saturated fat
it may be a better choice compared to
other saturated fats like butter
as it does have a more favorable effect
on cholesterol levels
and therefore is a totally fine option
for cooking with in moderation but if i
were madeleine's nutritionist
and i wanted her to up her healthy fats
by increasing their consumption
i would probably encourage her to stick
to the fats
that we have better evidence as being
healthy
so things like olive oil nuts seeds
avocado
flax etc it's also clear by watching her
take a spoonful of it
that it's not exactly a pleasurable
experience which
is really too bad i can think of so
many more delicious ways to add 100
calories of fat to your diet
whether that's some olive oil on bread a
handful of nuts
some avocado on salad etc anyways let's
eat something
that she actually wants to eat meal this
one has no added sugar ate banana
frozen blueberries i truly just
love oatmeal so much love
beefing up a packet of instant oatmeal
with lots of nutritious toppings and
add-ins
and this is a pretty nutrient-dense
oatmeal to start with actually
so i looked up this brand and it's got
gluten-free oats
buckwheat chia amaranth hemp sorghum and
quinoa
and that's it so no added sugar and it's
got an impressive six grams of protein
and four grams of fiber per pack so
we've got our fiber rich carbs and a
little bit of protein
and then we're gonna add in some more
energizing carbs in the blueberries
and the bananas so yummy but i would say
since she's using almond milk
we're not really getting much protein or
healthy fat in this meal
and it's a pretty low calorie meal as
well so my suggestion to madeleine to up
the satiety factor
would be to throw in a spoonful of
peanut butter add in a handful of hemp
flax or chia and use a higher protein
milk
like soy or pea protein instead of
almond
i start my day with celery juice i did
that a lot in lay and i just haven't
gotten into it here yet i'm sure i'll do
an update of what i eat in a day
once i've really gotten into my routine
here i've only been here for like a
month
i just enjoy kind of the ritualistic
aspect
that's such an l.a thing to say uh i
mean
i'm not going to rant about celery juice
because i feel like i have to do it
every damn video here on youtube
but to summarize because i'm tired no
celery juice won't cure cancer or
arthritis or inflammation or whatever
and if it makes you lose weight it's
because it's like
basically green water but also juicing
celery
rids it of its beneficial fibers so i'ma
say it one more time for the folks in
the back
drink your water eat your celery and
find some kind of daily food or drink
ritual that doesn't drain your pocket
for
very little nutritional value next
any kind of breaded chicken burger you
can also go without the breading
pan
[Music]
so to start off i'm obsessed with loose
kale it is my favorite
also referred to as dinosaur kale brand
new fresh kale it's super
crispy a bunch of lucinato kale another
boxed green like a baby kale or spinach
or something like that
and some balsamic vinegar okay so
madeleine is making her salad ahead of
time to bring
with her to her shoot she's got two
eaves veggie burgers cooked in oil
some dinosaur kale and more kale
i guess she likes kale and then she's
topping the whole thing off with some
balsamic vinegar
now i noticed that she's not adding any
oil to her salad
and that's totally cool if she likes to
avoid oils or whatever i'm not trying to
be the pro
oil police don't care i really don't
care if people limit their oils even
though it's obvious by the coconut oil
snack
that she doesn't but since she did
specifically say that she's having a
hard time getting in healthy fats
and she did specifically say that the
worst part of her day is eating a
spoonful of coconut oil
because of said challenge of getting
healthy fats
why not just throw a little bit of oil
on those greens
not to mention we know that all of those
fat soluble vitamins that kale is rich
in
like vitamin a and k depend on fat
to be absorbed so eating a fat-free
salad is
really kind of a missed opportunity for
really good nutrition
as for the chicken burgers i love a good
convenience option
especially since eaves is a canadian
brand so
represent um also two of these burger
patties together will deliver an
impressive 28 grams of protein
and four grams of fiber plus about a
gram of omega-3s so
i'm here for it and i'm also really just
happy that a celeb is eating an
accessible
convenience food that fans can actually
also buy and easily make
definitely appreciate the realness i
still think that this
is a pretty light lunch considering we
have just had our protein
and some veg so if she wanted she could
throw in some berries
or some pre-cooked grains or a bun for
her burger
just to add a little bit more energizing
carbs let's see what she has for snack
the blueberry thrill is just blueberries
i do no date almond butter
some kind of protein i choose clean
vegan protein and almond milk
i think okay so before she eats her
lunch because again
she pre-made it for work she did a
workout and she picked up a smoothie on
fruit home so this one she explains has
blueberries almond butter some vegan
protein powder and almond milk
and she requests no dates in hers
that sounds like a really great balanced
smoothie and
exactly how i would aim to build one at
home as well
we've got carbs and fiber from the
berries protein fiber and fat in the
almond butter
and some extra protein in the vegan
protein powder
and since she's assumedly getting like
20 to 30 grams of protein in this
smoothie
i actually don't think it's an issue in
the context of this day
that her breakfast was lacking in
protein and fat
some people just thrive on a higher carb
easy to digest breakfast and as long as
there's something substantial coming up
for snack
everything kind of balances itself out
so i often do give suggestions on how to
optimize
individual meals and snacks here the
reality is
none of that actually matters in real
life without the context
of an entire day or week let's see what
else she has to say
i don't believe in calorie counting if
anything look at calories make sure i'm
getting enough
listening to your body is so important
amazing you guys
know that's exactly what i stand for
here and i'm sure it's not easy to
navigate food and body image as a young
hollywood actress
hi is it possible for me to just get a
16 ounce cold brew please
again nothing much to say about that
other than the fact that it makes me
kind of anxious to be drinking coffee
later on the day
spoken like a true insomniac all right
let's see what she does at work i love
kombucha
i probably drink about one a day not
every day but i do like drinking it a
lot kombucha is healthy soda
so madeleine describes kombucha as a
healthy soda
and while i don't like to categorize or
dichotomize foods i mean
she's kind of not wrong i do love
anything that's fizzy and i'm a huge fan
of kombucha because
it is naturally low in calories and
sugar and it contains antioxidants
and organic acids from the tea plus some
probiotics
but as i discussed in my keltie o'connor
video the amount of probiotics that
you're getting
in a bottle of kombucha is pretty
negligible
in comparison to an actual supplement
we're talking the difference between
10 to 50 billion cfus and 5 to 10
million in a bottle of booch having said
that
i personally love this stuff i love that
it's tangy and
kind of sweet but not as sweet as soda
or juice
so if she likes the flavor as much as i
do
amazing great choice in my books
let's hit up dinner
[Music]
[Music]
that does look delish and i love how
easy it was to pull off
so this lentil pasta she's using is
higher in protein and fiber than
traditional pasta
so her bowl has about 21 grams of
protein
and six grams of fiber per serving so
that's pretty impressive
so that way we've got our protein in the
pasta fat in the vegan cheese
and lots of colorful fiber rich veg
love it this is absolutely something i
would make myself
and it's a simple fast meal for single
folks at home
i know how unmotivating it can be to
actually cook when
it's just you at home but i think that
madeleine really makes it look
totally doable and easy i think if i had
any suggestions again just because i'm
thinking back to
madeleine's self-confessed challenge of
being able to get in enough fat and
healthy fats
i would maybe add in like a good little
drizzle of olive oil on top
because while she might have pissed off
her italian fans with the lentil pasta
maybe she can earn back their respect
with
some liquid gold just saying
okay great i mean totally delicious
easy bedtime snack and i'm glad someone
has given cantaloupe some love
i feel like cantaloupe and honeydew
melon for that matter
are always the sad pale rejected
components of a fruit salad bowl
and then every restaurant like fills the
bowl with melon
and then carefully styles a few nice
pieces of strawberries and blueberries
and
cherries on top just to disguise the
fact that you're paying 15
for the fruit nobody actually wants so
it is nice to know somebody with as much
clout as
madeline is a fan maybe we can make
cantaloupe like the new cauliflower or
kale
just kidding please don't like
please don't we really don't need
another grocery store shortage during
covid
but anyways uh yeah i really
can't say anything negative about eating
cantaloupe for dessert
it's awesome it's easy it's nutritious
and it's affordable so
covid let's keep it that way now
let's answer a big question here is this
way of eating
balanced well like i said after watching
a bunch of madeleine's videos
it's pretty clear that food isn't
exactly her beat
so i'm making an analysis off of just
really one
main video but you guys asked me so much
about this particular day of eating
so why don't we break it down in short i
would say
yes madeleine's diet is totally balanced
and adequate
trigger warning and about talk numbers
but she is getting over
2500 calories 120 grams of protein
300 grams of carbs 66 grams of fiber
and 107 grams of fat so if we look
at that as macro percentages we're
looking at about a
46 carb 36 fat and 18
protein split so despite her concern
that she wasn't getting enough fat
for an average woman it looks like she's
doing just fine
if anything her carbs are on the lower
range of average
but still it all looks pretty balanced
and good to me
also her overall caloric intake looks
totally adequate for an active young
woman
which honestly is always refreshing to
see
her diet while not super exciting or
instagramable
is actually really nutrient-rich and
balanced my analysis didn't pull up any
major deficiencies or red flags
other than maybe vitamin b12 omega-3 and
d
all of which are common on a vegan diet
but i am hoping she is taking some
vegan-friendly vitamins
even though i didn't hear her talk
specifically about her supplement regime
in this video
in another video i did see her kind of
divvying up her vitamins so
i'm assuming she's getting all of those
in one go
i also appreciate how approachable her
meals are and that she relies on kitchen
shortcuts like jarred pasta sauce
and frozen veggie burgers to get a
nutritious meal on the table for one
and i get that when you're busy it is so
hard to be motivated to cook for
yourself so
bravo for her for making a priority
as for her perspective on food well i
didn't really hear her explicitly
demonize foods or give specific advice
around how people should be eating
even her whole coconut oil eating thing
was done strictly out of a
recommendation
by her nutritionist to get in more fat
and whether i agree with that
recommendation or not
i am glad that she leaves those things
really just to the pros
as another example in her self-care
video where she shares her skin care
routine
she specifically says that she's not a
dermatologist that
this is just what she does so it is
great to hear those disclaimers
peppered throughout i did see her do a
video on cryotherapy
but the worst that she said in that
video was that she was
pretty sure it would boost the effects
of her workout
cut and nondescript but also not untrue
from a recovery standpoint
it's just too bad that the guy at the
spa who she interviewed
spewed off a bunch of unsubstantiated
claims
and while there may be some health
benefits
linked to cryotherapy particularly when
it comes to
pain relief and exercise recovery there
isn't
a ton of great research to support
much else when it comes to the alleged
weight loss benefits
the theory behind this is that brown
adipose tissue in the body aka
brown fat burns fats to make energy
when the body is exposed to extreme cold
well one 2016 study found that three
minutes
at negative 166 fahrenheit twice a day
for five days
did not result in any weight or fat
changes in men
other studies found that about two hours
daily may reduce body fat by
two percent with another seeing up to
three percent
that may sound convincing but two hours
of your day
and we don't even know how long these
results last if at all
the fda has also even warned of the lack
of evidence for cryotherapy
and cautions towards the possible side
effects including numbness and skin
irritation
also a cryotherapy session will ring you
up about 100
of pop so i guess if madeleine's ad
revenue for a video on cryotherapy
covers the cost of the treatment
it's worth it for funsies but for the
average person
uh not so much ultimately i think her
channel is
pretty fun to watch mainly because she's
hilarious and
also she has amazing effing hair
so jelly um and i'm also not even a
riverdale fan so
that says something too but anyways this
is not really a channel that i would
recommend
or warn people about when it comes to
wellness information
because thankfully there isn't really
too much explicit wellness
recommendations to be found
and as it should be because she's an
actress
not a nutritionist or a dietitian or any
other health professional
but if you like riverdale you like
gingers or you like a lot of random
vlogs
you're probably going to like watching
madeleine pesch
and folks that is all for today i'm
keeping it short and sweet before my
baby wakes up screaming
to be fed oh my gosh because everything
is a race against his hunger cues so
that
my friends is mom life but there you go
if you like this video
please be sure to give it a thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you'd
like to see me review next
don't forget subscribe to the channel
and ring that little bell so you never
miss a video
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye